MEME REVIEW
Welcome! Welcome everyone! It's meme review time!
Yeah! Hell yeah!
That's my favorite show on YouTube!
Welcome to Meme Review. It's the show where we
explore and review the latest memes, of course, for the importance of history to document--
wHy Is My fOrEhEaD nOt iN tHiS sHoT?
A few weeks back on meme review 👏👏
We had a meme called the Tide Pods meme
And I'm sure you're familiar with it now,
now that it's gotten literally mainstream media attention
because people actually ate the Tide Pods.
[idiots]
You're not supposed to eat the Tide Pods. Oh you're crazy!
The joke was that you were wanting to eat them, but you don't eat them.
Don't eat the Tide Pods guys. [wtf is wrong with y'all]
I'm very serious right now as you can tell on my tone of voice and facial expression don't eat the Tide Pods
What are you crazy?
Oh my god. You could die!
Don't eat Tide Pods you ruined the meme you, ruined the meme. What do you want me to say? Good job.
*clap clap*
Now that the Tide Pod meme is dead we, though, have a substitute.
Don't worry.
So, don't be too sad we have [a] substitute meme.
And, of course, I am talking about the far superior
meme over Tide Pod, which is...
ISOPOD meme! That's right! Have you heard of
ISOPODS
Amazing size: 55 centimeters [22"].
Isopods: what do you know about them?
Well, number one
They are crust-- crustachaeans, not an insect. [he can't pronounce it]
[Google:] Crustacean.
They breathe through gills
And listen to this...
they don't urinate!
How crazy is that?
*Dude,* These peoples captured an isopod,
a giant isopod, befriended the isopod *talking in the background*
May I even say, beloved, the isopod
[In the video:] *What is it? I have no idea.*
*It's like*
[queue the Lion King music]
*HIS NAME IS BENJI!*
What a wonderful name for an isopod.
Shh- I sure wish I had an isopod pets
Now don't worry these can live on land for a couple hours, and they can literally go years without eating
They even brought Benji to Hooters
[LOOK AT THE WAITER'S FACE]
[Waiter:] *I'm done with you guys*
*laughing*
*pewds cringing*
I know this might seem cruel, but they did return Benji to water.
Now of course we don't want to eat..
the isopod, we just want to befriend them.
Who doesn't want an isopod friend?
I would never say no. If you're an isopod watching right now:
(CALL ME)
Look how cute they are: tickle tickle.
Aw, that's an anime girl and her isopod-
-pet that's adorable.
Look how much that cat is having a good time with this isopod friend.
Oh look, another anime girl with her isopod.
I sure am jealous-
-for everyone is having an isopod.
Here they're having a little tea party.
Oh, look how cute, look how happy she- ohh- the-
She's happy with her isopod.
Isopod also...
Can be quite fierce, if they want to.
Here's footage of isopods
capturing a shark.
They protect...
But they also attacc.
But when its isopod hours, that's when it gets real.
Can I get an isopod hours in the chat?
[impending ear rape]
[told ya]
It's isopod hour everybody!
Hell yeah!
That's really cool.
Now I know it's you're wondering: Whe- where do these come from?
Well, they are technically bottom dwellers,
but I do also think they come from the old game, Halo; on Xbox.
*chuckle*
*Halo theme playing.*
OH I LOVE THEM
[hit it from the back bitch and isopod will eat you]
The Tide Pod meme was horrible meme that led to a lot of people suffering in pain [no shit]
Now I feel like we can do something positive with a pod meme.
The isopod meme can really take off and bring happiness and joy on the earth,
and give life meaning to some people,
as myself for example.
I will rate the isopod meme a solid six and uh-- f--
--five. 6 and a 5 everybody.
The isopod, 6.6 because they're so damn cute, and I just can't ha-
6.8 and that's final. Isopod, let's see where it goes is it isopod hour yet?
It just finished. It just finished *sad*
NEXT MEME
This meme is blowing up can we get a siren of meme attack? *siren sound*
wOaH
wOoAh
Wow, this meme is about to blow, this meme is everywhere
I don't know what this meme is called
Basically: having some sort of uhh
Giants attacking, versus something very small.
Here you have seniors
Versus hot freshmen girl.
Here you have the boogie man,
versus: my foot hanging off the bed.
Here you have
me
Versus: unfinished water bottle by my bed at 3 am.
There's also: me, my cousin, and her virginity. *laughs*
We have: normies, and this meme in two weeks.
Pretty much, pretty much.
Minecraft invite from Kevin,
versus: me doing homework, on a school night.
Wow,  it's hard to resist an invite of Minecraft from Kevin.
My uncle after a few drinks,
[versus] my 7 year old-- *shout sound*
Me, versus: my phone on full brightness at 1:00 a.m.
Wow, such power.
Me and just...
women.
Which reminds me, this meme is really just a me
respecting women meme, but they just changed it with Giants
*ha ha ha*
It still works because there's so many video-- There's so many pictures to go from
and there's so many
'relatable moments' such as: me,
and my pencil that I just dropped
Incredible. FBI employee, my laptop's camera.
The one to establish a worldwide communist regime in which I am Supreme Leader
and take all the funds for the government,
Thus everyone is equal in the money
They have, but nobody has enough money to form a resistance and plot a government takeover.
Versus: my sanity
Me
Versus:
The soda that someone left
This meme format,
dead memes,
Instagram. Pretty much.
Kid who works - kid whose dad work for Microsoft,
my Xbox live account.
You don't want to mess with someone that knows a dad that works for Xbix.
My headache, versus, ibuprofen
People spamming this meme format
my enjoyment of this meme
Well, this is a very adaptabilitible [wow poods] meme
I don't- it's, it's so, *kiss* fresh that I don't even know its name
I'm gonna immediately give it two extra bonus points for being, *kiss* fresh
Oh, no the bonus points have been lost, this meme is already dying
*autistic screeching*
Giving it a five this meme gets a five
*clap*
Next meme please thank you, let's move on.
It's time for--
BONUS MEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEME
OOOOOOOOOOOH BONUS MEEEEEEEEEEEME
Good time and good luck for your good fortune must be with you.
The BONUS MEME for this week is connect four.
The connect four meme.
It basically started with the artwork of this classic connect four game,
where they're just having such a great time.
And people just started to- *chuckles*
To photoshop it. It's really. That's it. That's it. Here we have a connect one
That's a tricky one. We have conec one.
The one game.
We have a connect strap,
which is-- who does that, come on you gotta live life on the edge.
We have Connecticut!
And is face is Connecticut.
That's great. That's a great one. I enjoy that game
NUT
*wheeze*
How creative you can be!
Connect child oh, it's a reverse meme excellent, excellent.
We have: connect the evidence of election rigging.
We have: bit connect four, the classic.
We have: connect loss.
Really? The classic meme that somehow doesn't die
Net yes, of course net is great to play. I love net!
The necc. Oh wow,  that's also a very exciting...
*laughs*
Help! I glued my hands to my face.
Can you stop?
Thanks.
Good meme!
Cone! I love playing cone. That's awesome!
Hilarious pepperoni! Look at that pepperoni.
That's a very funny pepperoni.
And of course
My personal favorite: connect crab. It's tricky.
Gonna rate the four connect
a solid pa- pa- pa- pa- pa- pa- pa- pa- pa- pa-...
5.7.5 everybody.
Meme
Review.
Hope you guys enjoyed, leave a *clap clap* if you enjoyed and as always remember to have a great ... smile :)
[video still isn't 10 minutes yet prepare for cringe]
[there it is!]
*clap* *clap*
[buy pewds' 399$ chair]